[Music]
I Love is
alive so we
begin foolish our heart on the table
stumbling
[Music]
it I love it there a
flame
with now and
then will
C it
in wherever you
go whatever you
do you know these Reckless thought M I'm
following
you how falling for
you whatever you
do cuz baby you show me so many things
that I never
knew whatever it
t baby I'll do it for
you all love is
aive and so we begin
foolishly laying our hearts on the table
stumbling
in I know there
[Music]
a
now
C you were so
young oh and I was so free
I may have been young but baby that's
not what I want it to
be well you are the
one oh why was it
me CU baby show me so many things that I
never
see whatever you
need baby you got it from me
our love is
alive and so we
begin foolishly laying our hearts on the
table stumbling
in I love in the
flame
with now and
then will catch us stumbling in
stumbling
in
stumbling foolishly laying our hearts on
the table
[Music]
so fun fact exactly 30 seconds after I
ended that take the sky opened up up and
uh dropped a huge Deluge down on Tacoma
Park where I was shooting that video it
was only by the narrowest of margins
that I got my camera and myself out of
the rain in time so uh yeah we'll call
that uh quite the dramatic way to end
that performance um any who so uh real
quickly I just want to put out a thank
you to ultra PO for sponsoring this
video and giving me a reason to go out
and try and squeeze in a performance
right before for uh the sky opened up on
me uh if you'd like to grab a set of
those orb poy Pro from Ultra po they are
officially back in stock uh you can do
that using the promo code drexfactor
with a zero instead of an o a checkout
over ultra.com that gets you 5% off of
your order thank you once again Ultra
poy for supporting my uh my flow
sessions and giving me an excuse to get
out and go
flow and speaking of thank yous big
thanks to the Friends of the channel
That is uh big thanks to to dark monk
fire Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroar light toys spinballs and
Ultra poy thank you one and all for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible and if you out there
watching would like to learn more about
all these companies you can check out
the links that I have down in my uh
video description and finally a huge
thank you to uh the non- buus friend of
the channel That is Becca beon and thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission and final
final uh this and all the videos on my
channel would not be possible without my
amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a huge shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now y'all
Rock um they as well as the many other
supporters that I have on patreon help
to make this video and all the videos on
this channel possible and if you are not
currently a supporter but you would like
to become one you can do that by heading
on over to patreon.com drexfactor poo
and signing up there not only will you
get access to some really awesome re
Awards but you'll be helping me out in
my mission to bring po spending and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you if you'd
like to Che if you'd like to check out
more of my uh flow sessions like this
one I will go ahead and include a link
to a playlist of those down in the
description as well as up on screen
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out and flow yourself today and I'll
see you with a new video real soon take
care now peace